翻訳: Yuri Ueda
校正: Hiroko Kawano
ある日の午前０時
私は１人で壁を見つめていました
その壁には
未来のクルマのアイデアを書いた付箋が
100枚以上貼られていて
その中から 私は
１枚を手に取りました
その付箋にはこう書いてありました
空飛ぶクルマ
そう 忘れもしない 2013年の秋
私は 空飛ぶクルマを作る事を決意しました
まずは このムービーをご覧ください
[ア ワールド・スモーレスト フライングカー
スカイドライブ]
（波の音）
（音楽）
（音楽終了）
私の本職は 自動車エンジニアで
普通のサラリーマンです
ですが 業務外で
総勢30名のボランティアメンバーと
大学の先生方と共に
空飛ぶクルマの開発を行っています
目指すは 2050年までに
誰もが 自由に
空を飛べる時代を作ること
そしてまずは
2020年 東京オリンピックの開会式で
空飛ぶクルマを使って
聖火台に火を灯すことを狙っています
先ほどのムービーは
そのシーンを表現したものです
今日は 空飛ぶクルマを開発する中で学んだ
「限界を突破する２つの方法」を紹介します
そもそも 何故
空飛ぶクルマを作ろうと思ったのか？
それは 私の幼少期に遡ります
小さい頃 イタリア生まれの真っ赤な
スーパーカーに憧れ
「自分も将来 憧れの対象となる
クルマを作ってみたい」と
思ったのがきっかけでした
小中学生の頃は 友達からの電話で
「あっちの駐車場に
すごいクルマが停まってるぞ！」
という声を聞くと
カメラを持って一目散に直行し
前から 後ろから そして下からと
パシャパシャ撮っていました
また 作ったクルマのプラモデルの数は
優に100台は超えていました
中間テストや期末テストの度に
１台また１台と増えていきました
みなさんの中でも
テスト期間中に
部屋の掃除をしてしまったような
人もいるかと思います
私の場合は テストの度に
部屋がクルマで埋まっていきました
そして大学に入ってからは
その思いが高じて
実際に人が乗れるレーシングカーを
作ってしまいました
もちろん１人でという訳ではありませんが
大学の仲間と一緒に
金属を削ったり溶接をしたりして
年に１台クルマを作り レースに出ていました
そんな車好き少年が
７年前 自動車エンジニアとしての
スタートラインを切りました
しかし 世の中では
「若者の車離れ」ということが言われ
車好きの私としては
とても寂しい気持ちでいました
自分の好きなものが
世の中から消えていってしまう —
そんな危機感を抱き
４年前に会社の同期数名と
新しい車のコンセプトを
考える団体を立ち上げました
半年間で100個以上のアイデアを出し
その中から１つに絞ることにしました
最後は 言い出しっぺである私に
その選択権が委ねられました
「自分は本当に何がしたいのか？」
来る日も来る日も考え続けました
すると 自分が小さい頃に感じたのと
同じようにワクワクし
最も夢があると感じたアイデアがありました
それが「空飛ぶクルマ」だったのです
他のアイデアは
やれば出来そうだったのに対し
空飛ぶクルマは一見できそうもないものだからこそ
次世代に価値が生み出せるのではないか？
そう思ったのです
ここで みなさんに
ちょっとお伺いしたいのですが
この中で車が好きという方は
どのぐらいいらっしゃいますか？
ありがとうございます
でもやっぱり少ないですね
（笑）
では 「空飛ぶクルマ」と聞いて
ワクワクする方はどのぐらい
いらっしゃいますか？
ありがとうございます
ほとんど全員ですね
私も当時 とってもワクワクし
思わずこのアイデアを選んでしまいました
後から考えてみると
これが限界を突破する
１つ目の方法だということに気付きました
すなわち ワクワクする気持ちに
正直に飛び込んでみることだったのです
実は それまでの私は
とかくできることから考えてしまいがちで
ワクワクする ぶっ飛んだことに挑戦しよう
というマインドは持っていませんでした
しかし この時は余計なことを考えず
自分の気持ちに正直に従ったのです
その後 メンバーに気持ちを打ち明けると
みんなも私と同じようにワクワクし
賛同をしてくれました
しかし アイデアが決まっても
具体的にどうすればいいかがわかりません
そこで 各自が思い描く空飛ぶ車を絵に落とし
イメージをすり合わせていきました
冒頭のムービーのように
垂直に離着陸できるようにしたいということで
原理を検討していった結果
マルチコプター
通称ドローンと呼ばれるものに
行き当たりました
2013年の当時 まだ日本では
ドローンというものが
一般的ではなかったため
どういう原理で飛ぶのかも
良くわかりませんでした
市販品を買ってきましたが
中身はブラックボックスです
そこで原理を理解するため
まずは自分たちで作ってみることにしました
これが最初の試作機です
ミニ四駆のモーターに４枚のプロペラをつけ
４つの回転数を合わせれば飛ぶだろう
ということでトライをしました
実際 浮くことは浮いたのですが
すぐに傾いてしまいました
今考えてみると
姿勢を検知するセンサーと
それを制御するコンピュータが
必要であることは明白だったのですが
当時はそれすらも
わかっていませんでした
そこで 大学や社会人の友人で
制御に詳しい人に声をかけていきました
すると
「なんだかよくわからないけど面白そう！」
と協力してくれる事になり
機体と制御プログラムの開発が始まりました
半年間をかけて 実物大の1/5サイズの
試作機を完成させました
今日はそれをお持ちしております
こちらです
４枚のプロペラで垂直に浮き
３つのタイヤで走ることができます
ここでは狭いので飛ばす事は出来ませんが
走って飛んでいく様子を
動画でご覧いただきたいと思います
車のように地上を走り
そこからそのまま飛んでいく事ができます
（モーター音）
その後 できた試作機を持って
展示会に出たり
インターネットで
情報発信をしていきました
すると 様々なスキルを持つ
エンジニアやビジネスマンの人たちが
「自分も手伝いたい」と
意外にも仲間に入ってくれるようになりました
今振り返ってみると
これが限界を突破するもう１つの方法
であることに気付きました
すなわち
「やり続けながら仲間を募ること」でした
最初のうちは人数が少なく
１人で進めるような日もありました
そのため すぐに困難にぶちあたり
思うように進みません
しかし 興味を持ってくれた人や
スキルのある人に
「こういう事がしたいんだけど
手伝ってくれない？」と
声をかけていった結果
どんどんと仲間が増えていきました
今では総勢30名のコアメンバーと
70名のサポートメンバーが
入ってくれています
中でも ドローンの
姿勢制御を研究されている大学の先生や
大型の試作機を作られている方にも
入っていただくことができました
その結果 現在では
実物大のサイズの実験機で
実験を行っており
数秒間の安定浮上に成功しています
また このように活動しながら
情報発信を続けていると
思いがけないことも起こります
小学校から大学 そして企業の方からも
「夢を追いかける姿勢を伝えてほしい」と
講演の依頼をいただくようになりました。
中でも プログラミングを学んでいる
中高生の人たちが
我々が作っていたシミュレーターを
見てこう言い出しました
「自分たちも空飛ぶ車のゲームを作りたい！」
最初は「中高生がゲームを作れるのだろうか？」と
懐疑的でした
しかし 作り始めてから半年後
なんと完成したゲームを持って展示会に出展し
大好評を得るまでに至ってしまったのです
今日は このゲームを
少しお見せしたいと思います
（音楽）
空中にある輪っかをくぐって
いかに速くゴールできるかを競うゲームです
途中にあるコインを取ると
タイムが減るというボーナスを作ったり
このBGMもオリジナルで作ってしまいました
（音楽終了）
このように彼女らも
「自分でゲームを作りたい」
という気持ちに正直に従って行動し
仲間を集め 一歩一歩
実現していったのです
元々この活動は 次世代に夢を届けたい
という思いで始めましたが
まさか 中高生たちがこのような形で
実現していってくれるとは
夢にも思いませんでした
もちろん達成感ばかりではありません
航空関係者の方から
「そんな原理じゃ無理だよ」とか
経営のプロの方から
「市場がないんじゃないか？」
「そもそも飛ぶ必要があるのか？」と言われ
正直落ち込む事もあります
しかし すでに技術的に実証は出来ており
海外ではベンチャーや大手航空機メーカーが
年々ひどくなる大都市の渋滞を
回避する手段として
空飛ぶ車の開発を急いでいます
特にアメリカでは
インフラの整備やルール作り
さらには空飛ぶタクシーとしての
配車サービスの検討までも行っています
もはや時間の問題であり
我々も早くやらなければ
ならないと思っています
私たちは ワクワクする
夢のようなアイデアに対し
「自分ではできない」と思いがちです
しかし 本当にそうでしょうか？
飛び込んでやってみたら
意外と不可能ではないかもしれません
さらに それを１人で実現しようとすると
能力の限界にぶち当たります
でも １人でやる必要はないのです
情報発信をしていないだけで
みなさんの周りには
意外と多くの協力者がいるはずです
まず ワクワクする気持ちに
正直に飛び込んでみること
そして やり続けながら仲間を募ること
これが私なりの限界を突破する２つの翼です
この２つが揃えば
自分が思っている以上に遠くまで
飛ぶことができるのかもしれません
みなさんにとっての
空飛ぶクルマはなんですか？
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）